- What's your go-to in the
city, when people come?
- My wife and I, we go near
Santa Monica in the west side.
There's a Sawtelle Japantown,
there's a Sawtelle District,
- [Kelly Clarkson] Oh!
where there's a lot of
Asian-American cuisine.
And it's not only
Japanese cuisine, Korean
cuisine, Chinese food, the boba-
- Wait, where is this?
- It's on Sawtelle, it's
called the Sawtelle District.
If you even Google it, or go on YouTube,
it's Sawtelle Japantown.
- Okay.
- But it's Asian American
cuisine everywhere.
And it is really amazing,
and I highly recommend it.
Doesn't get a lot of press
that a lot of people say,
but for me that's like my favorite
when I first moved out here.
And when I first got married to my hoe,
her last name, it's for true.
(laughter)
So it's fine! I can say it!
Hoes pimping ain't easy!
(laughter)
- I love you so much. You're
gonna pay for that. (laughs)
- I'm gonna pay for that. (laughs)
And so we would go around
Sawtelle when we were dating
when we first got married
and it's just a lovely time
and I highly recommend that.
- I wanna go, I've never been!
- You'd love it. You'd love it.
- I would love it!
If you love any Asian-American cuisine,
- I love Asian food, yep!
- Chinese, Korean, Japanese,
and they have pastries
there, Beard Papa's.
It's all these amazing.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Wow!
- Yeah. It's so cool.
- See, people always think
that I've lived here for 20.
I haven't, I've been to
in Texas or Tennessee.
- [Ken Jeong] Right.
This is the first I've
actually really lived here.
- [Ken Jeong] Yeah.
- So I'm new too, so I'm
learning the top three as well
and all these places stuff.
- No, Absolutely. Yeah.
- It's so good! But is it
true that you got to work
with one of your idols this
summer? That's awesome.
- Yes! I just did a Netflix
limited series with Mike Myers
from Austin Powers and Wayne's World.
Just literally one of my idols growing up.
And it literally just one
of the reasons why I got
into comedy in the first place.
And I'm sure you've had
this too, where every day
on set was a pinch me moment.
- Oh yeah!
- Because he's literally
one of the reasons
why I just wanted to get in a comedy
and just to work with
one of my heroes and just
I still have this, every day!
You just go into work, smiling,
and then you leave smiling.
And that's just,
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah!
- If you have any job like
that in anything that you do,
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah!
- God bless us all. So it was so much fun-
- I Know, I always like to
remind myself, think of yourself
as that 10 year old kid.
- That was just like-
- [Ken Jeong] Yes!
- You know, remember that feeling.
- [Ken Jeong] Yes, yes!
- So yeah.
- Did you shout any lines?
Did you do the pinky?
- Did I do anything?
Well just among friends,
it's become of the vernacular of
"we're not worthy or what",
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah, yeah!
all these things!
- Yeah!
And I remember one time, on
set, we're just joking around.
I was feeling more comfortable around 'em
and I was just starting to,
I was like, "oh, I have, oh"
(laughter)
- "Something in my teeth!" (laughs)
- Yeah. You just really
didn't wanna make, but-
- Yeah, I'm a tool! I walked
right into Kevin Hart.
I did this show with him and I walked in
and I'd just seen his special.
And I was like, "bop, bop, bop!"
(laughter)
I was, if you haven't seen
his special, it's amazing.
And it'll make you so happy-
- Well, Kevin's a friend of mine.
So you walked in and it's
more like, "bop, bop, bop!
(laughter)
- I know! (laughs)
- What? What!? He's short!
Revealed by Dr. Ken,
who's almost as short as
him, but slightly taller.
(laughter)
- He's slightly taller! (laughs)
No, but you can see his face.
He was like, oh, you're the
first one ever to do that.
(laughter)
I was like, I know I'm a tool!
But do people quote any
of your stuff to you?
- Yes. All the time.
- [Kelly Clarkson] That's cool!
- Yeah. It's cool. But it's the hangover,
and it's like you're saying,
- [Kelly Clarkson] Ah!
- [Ken Jeong] "thank you!"
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yes!
- But, right when the hangover came out,
I was at an ATM where I live
and this dude is in a
convertible, just staring at me
and I'm getting money, just staring at me.
I'm getting money, just staring at me-
- Like, "Am I about to be robbed?"
(laughter)
- He didn't know what was going on!
And there was a stoplight,
it was red, it turned green.
And as he goes through, he looks at me.
He goes "Too-da-loo, mother (beep)!"
"Woo woo woo woo woo woo
woo woo woo woo woo woo!"
(laughter)
(applause)
- That's amazing!
- [Ken Jeong] Yeah.
- That's amazing.
- Really happened. (laughs)
- I love that! I just
get my name yelled out.
'Cause the 40 year old version,
I wouldn't even a part of it!
- Oh, that's right!
- [Kelly Clarkson] I
wasn't even a part of it!
People just yell my name
and I'm like, "it's never happened,"
"you're so original!" Cut.
(laughter)
- I'm like, it's never. Yeah. I'm like,
but I actually don't make fun
of them cause I'm that person.
But yeah, it's a really cool
thing though, to be like
it's a big thing in pop culture.
It's huge!
- This is beyond
a dream come true because
I was just 15 years ago.
I was a doctor who just
wanted to get into comedy just
even just to act and to
be a character actor.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
It didn't was not trying
to be famous in any way.
So for me to be on this
level at this point
in my life, it's, it's always
beyond surreal. So thank you.
- Great things happen to great people.
(applause)
- Yeah!
- That's you! And we're all
just learning from. Thank you.
- Well, Asian Americans
everywhere have also
taken big strides to stand
up to bias this last year.
- Yeah.
- Which is horrible, but many
are still experiencing grief
due to social injustice and
loss due to the pandemic.
So as someone in the medical field,
- Yeah.
- stress and living in
a stressful environment
and things this past two years.
- Yeah.
- It's been so much happening.
Do you have any, I don't know.
Do you have any coping skills
or anything for people?
- It's just important to know that
we're all in this together.
I mean your actions affect our actions.
Our actions affect your actions.
We are here together and
right now, thank God we're
in a safe environment
where we're being cautious.
But if we're being careful
for ourselves, I'm gonna be
careful for each and every one of you
and vice versa, we need each other.
(applause)
- To survive! And there is no one person
that is more important than the other.
We need each other to survive.
- No one's exempt from that.
- We need each other,
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- and we can't do it without each other.
- Again, it's a movement of us.
It's a medical movement of us,
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- as a globe to take care of each other.
We take care of ourselves. We
can take care of each other.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
And as entertainers,
sometimes we're fortunate to
impact lives where we don't
even know that we're impacting.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah!
- It's the same thing.
When it comes to this pandemic,
we're impacting lives just
by being cautious and
doing the right thing
and following the science
we're impacting other lives
we don't even know.
- Yeah.
- That we're impacting.
I think that's important
to have that responsibility
and to wear it positively.
- Absolutely. And it's so
funny because it's interesting.
I just dropped my kid off at
school this morning, River,
and just our conversation in a car.
If we really, I know it
sounds like so simple
but if you really just
thought how our children are
and how we teach our children to act
in school and how to respect others.
- Yeah.
And, it's just so funny
if we just really paid attention
to what we're saying to
them and actually implement
in our own world, it would change a lot.
- Yeah. Absolutely. Absolutely!